[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back
to your fantasy fire drill i am matt
camp and we're going to help you put
together the best fantasy football squad
in your drafts you can win champion
chips
in 2021 one full week of pre-season
action is now behind us that gives us
that much more to dive into maybe your
drafts are coming up in the next couple
of days or even this weekend if you can
wait certainly try to do that because
there's a lot of things up in the air
right now we'll try to touch on all of
that but you've been getting your
questions in and you can continue to do
that in the br app maybe you were
watching games this weekend you threw
them right in there so did you thought
of them that's a good thing to do write
them down get them in there i will be
answering them throughout the show and
for a couple more thursdays here at 1pm
eastern on the br app your fantasy fire
drill is underway let's get into it a
lot of people this time of year want to
know about sleepers so let's get things
kicked off with some sleeper
conversation we'll start with your
questions m cost is going to start
things off who is your biggest sleeper
at tight end m costa this has been a
very popular question i'm glad you asked
it because it's going to help a lot of
you watching out there
the position is a bit top-heavy there's
some strong names at the top you have
travis kelsey's and george kittles and
darren wallers of the world we know that
already but who's going to make that
leap who's going to help you can get
later on let's head down to new orleans
because adam troutman is a name you need
to be looking at you see his adp way off
the board right now he's not even going
off the board as a top 15 tight end but
no more josh hill and more importantly
no more jared cook for the new orleans
saints they let both of those guys go in
the offseason and we'll talk more about
him later michael thomas is a complete
m.i.a and a tbd as to when he will be
back so
adam troutman could be a name you get
later on in your draft who comes through
as a potential top 10 option at the
position targets are going to go to
alvin kamara we know that but who else
is going to get him i think troutman's
got a shot to eat some of those up in
his second year let's get another
question in here from uh spreevot
biggest sleeper at running back looking
at gus edwards gus edwards is not a bad
one i wouldn't say he's a complete
sleeper because as we saw last season
the ravens are willing to keep him in
the mix even with jk dobbins a lot of
people myself included high on j.k
dobbins this year but
gus edwards regardless of the role of
j.k dobbins i think gus edwards will
still have some flex appeal this is a
run first offense they are more than
willing to use multiple running backs
and even lamar jackson in their run
first offense so i think dobbins will
see the most touches i think at minimum
gus edwards will be a weekly flex option
now if dobbins were to go down in this
offense well gus edwards could lead the
way and end up being at minimum a solid
rb2 with some upside so that's the name
i would think of we'll get to a couple
more coming up here in just a bit
because austin johnson keeping it pretty
general austin says who are the biggest
sleepers this season we'll hit this a
couple more times leading in to week
number one a couple more shows to go let
me give you a couple names at running
backs since that's what we're talking
about right now let's go to a team that
has an offense that you want a piece of
that's the green bay packers and let's
talk about aj dillon the packers still
have aaron jones aaron jones is going to
be probably gone in the first 10 or 12
picks of your fantasy draft however
because it is a great team and when in
doubt you want to grow a piece of a
great offense i would take a look at aj
dillon flash and you see the adp by the
way inside the top 100 for the clear
number two back in green bay look jamal
williams used to be the number two to
aaron jones and he had fantasy value
even when jones was healthy but the key
to me if you're looking for a sleeper
when jones was banged up
mul williams could step in there and be
a top 15 running back i believe aj
dillon is a more talented far more
talented player than jamal williams so
if aaron jones were to go down
i think you're looking at a top 15
running back in aj dillon speaking of
jamal williams he stayed in the nfc
north this offseason but he went from
green bay to detroit and jamal williams
we have seen in previous years if you
have aaron jones jamal williams has been
a thorn in your side i get that but
jamal williams has proven to be a proven
and reliable fantasy commodity now
deandre swift's gonna lead the way for
detroit i think you know that but i
don't think it's that clear of a lead i
think we could be in a 1a 1b situation
similar to what williams did at times in
green bay in previous seasons and don't
forget this wide receiver group in
detroit might be one of the worst if not
the worst in the league so they're going
to want to run the ball dan campbell
football guy as a head coach as we know
you've heard plenty of them he's going
to want to run the football i think both
backs will have roles uh i would take a
look at tamales who by the way if he
would lead the way potentially if
swiffer to go down you're looking at a
solid rb2 so those are the sleepers
those are the names you're going to make
an effort to go get but what about the
players you should be avoiding i have
some names i'm going to get to but your
questions first and let's start with jay
decio should i avoid daryl henderson
feel like i should jay decio
you should not
we talked about daryl henderson a little
bit last week but with cam makers out
for the season due to a torn achilles
this is daryl henderson's backfield now
when he led the way and it wasn't for
all of last season he was real good this
is a player who won you fantasy matchups
at times his adp of 70.3 right now to me
um pretty solid his adp puts him around
rb 23 off the board i have him at 20. i
think he could be a top 15 running back
this year because matthew stafford takes
the rams offense to the next level i
think matthew stafford is going to help
this rams offense on unlock their true
potential and with daryl henderson
leading the way that's scoring
opportunities once again when in doubt
get a piece of a good offense this could
be a great offense and daryl henderson
should be someone jay dezio you should
not be avoiding i'd be trying to get
daryl henderson this year let's move on
to another one of your questions here as
we talk about players potentially avoid
team out says thinking about avoiding
mike evans
good idea or bad idea tim out
bad idea now last year mike evans
finished the season
has wide receiver 10. we know chris
godwin missed some time
look where he's at though right now
80p of 37 12 team league that's the top
of the fourth round
to me
he's wide receiver
14.
that's what his adp is that's why i have
him ranked he finished as wide receiver
10. so you already have the regression
which is fair to expect
built in for mike evans you're not
paying a premium price in fact his value
has dropped a little bit should it have
probably not maybe a tad but the fact of
the matter is is that he's still in a
great offense even with godwin back the
opportunities will be there and scoring
opportunities will be there you don't
like to rely on touchdowns but the
opportunities will be there for mike
evans we know he's a great red zone
threat as well he is someone j mounts
that i would be looking to go get and
not avoid let's move on here uh to you
two tried and uh you tried says thoughts
on logan thomas reliable logan thomas
tight end for the washington football
team ryan fitzpatrick there now i'm
gonna say reliable and much like mike
evans while not a superstar player you
see the numbers last year for logan
thomas
his adp 97.7 certainly not expensive
has him around the ninth tight end off
the board
so do i
but last year he finished as the sixth
best tight end so once again regression
is built in you don't have to pay for
the numbers he put up last season in
fact that regression's in there a little
bit further samuel just getting off the
pup list logan thomas
is not an exciting name i get that is he
going to win you weeks like a travis
kelsey or a george kittle no probably
not
but reliability at tight end this year
could be a premium i think logan thomas
will give you that reliability so you
tried try to go get logan thomas now
those are some questions you have on
players to avoid what about some players
i'm looking to avoid and this is
something we can revisit the next couple
of shows before the season gets underway
i want to start with a name that's come
up many times
in the news on this show last week this
week michael thomas saints wide receiver
well that's nice that he's listed as a
saints wide receiver but he's not the
number one guy that we know of the past
in fact we don't even know when he's
going to be back on the field the delay
in the surgery the lack of communication
with the team these are all red flags to
me drew brees not being the quarterback
of this team anymore all of this is bad
yet
you see the adp 60
63.3
we're talking here you know fifth round
sixth round
and even still that's the 27th wide
receiver off the board he's my wide
receiver 46. we don't know when this guy
is getting on the field they are not as
good as they were last year even when he
gets on the field he's not going to have
a normal offseason he's going to need
some time to get up to speed i don't
think you need to pay a premium for
michael thomas so at that adp he is
extremely overpriced do not pay for name
value assess the situation now let's go
to another player i like as a talent but
the situation and the volume concerns me
we go out west to vegas and let's talk
about josh jacobs for the las vegas
raiders the numbers last year very solid
you see his adp around 28.3 that's about
the 17th running back off the board
right in the middle of the rb2 tier
that's fine
but to me he's a little bit lower he's
more on the back end of the rb2 tier
rb-21 why is that two reasons number one
too much to our chagrin they sign kenyon
brig now kenyon drake i don't think it's
as skilled as jack jacobs but you know
he can contribute and he can contribute
somewhere where josh jacobs hasn't been
called upon and that is the passing game
josh jacobs is a better running back in
reality versus fantasy because his
potential and his fantasy numbers are
limited by the fact that he's not
involved that much in the passing game
that's been the last couple of years and
then they bring kenyon drake who can
handle a lot of that role
i just think right now not a complete
avoid but at his current price tag i
have to say josh jacobs not worth it
where he's going because of the presence
of kenya drake and one more that came up
and this was i think someone people were
hoping to go get with upside miles
gaskin for the miami dolphins rb 20 run
right now in adp 47th overall i moved
him down to 29. brian flores in miami
talking about a three-back rotation and
using gaskin and situational spots
that does not make me feel good there
are no definitive statements saying
miles gasket is going to be our guide
and let's be honest miami's probably an
average offense so do you want a player
who is still trying to find his way in a
rotation on an average offense at that
adp no i do not now you mentioned some
injuries here let's get a little deeper
into injuries and get some of your
questions as it relates to some players
who may have some question marks right
now and this is a big one this is from
knr 322 should we be concerned about
stefan diggs knee where do you see him
landing compared to other wide receivers
i'm going to give you my top five wide
receivers coming up a little bit later
and stefan diggs may appear there
however
we did heard her hear earlier this week
from head coach sean mcdormand german of
the buffalo bills that this knee issue
continues to be sticking around it
didn't seem problematic but mcdermott
also said that diggs will continue to
miss practice we're in the middle of
august we're getting towards the end of
august we've only had one preseason game
i understand that
but
this is a team that thinks they can go
to the super bowl and they have fair
expectations to do so they can be
playing extremely safe with stefan dicks
he is their star wide receiver but this
is someone you would probably be
thinking about as a top five minimum top
10 fantasy recipient for the year and
now there's a knee issue and this is not
a player who has done well playing
through injuries in the past it's just
this situation to keep an eye on if
you're drafting in the next couple of
days
maybe you look somewhere else instead of
stefan diggs just to be safe we're just
in a little extra cautious mode right
now t bucket says is michael thomas
worth keeping in a dynasty league so
everything i said about michael thomas
earlier pertained to redraft draft done
the season's over and you move on
dynasty leagues you know you're going to
keep somebody around who might be
injured he's going to miss some time as
we know it's going to be a lot of time
but in the dynasty league how do i treat
him
if right now you look at your dynasty
league roster and say i'm hurting i'm
not that good i need some help elsewhere
i probably won't contend this season
maybe you look to trade a michael thomas
to a powerhouse team who could take on
an injured player and weather that score
where you may not be able to do so and
then they could take on that risk if
you're not a very good team right now
because he's such a big question mark in
a dynasty league i might be looking to
shock him and even when he comes back
what level is he going to be at there's
a lot of question marks and red flags
and that red color for that ankle injury
is right on for michael thomas i have
nothing positive to say about him
let's move on to another one uh adam
asks should i keep deandre swift
or darren waller i am i'm a big darren
waller fan i think he's a difference
maker at the tight end position and i
think it's actually a no-brainer now
he's been a little bit banged up nothing
really to worry about here he's a true
stud at his position i like swift i
don't call him a snud in this position
we talked about jamal williams earlier
waller is a difference maker here
i can't get super excited about swift
both guys as we know a little bit banged
up here waller's an obvious keep to me
and like i said somebody who i think
could finish top three at the position
this year all right let's move on to the
wide receiver position you have some
questions there we're gonna get into my
top five wide receivers but uh thoughts
here from rashad johnson he says
thoughts on deontay and dj more this
season this is my wide receiver stack
but ended up with najee gibson and zeke
well let's start with the the running
backs there because that's three of my
top 13 running backs so if you're gonna
go right there theoretically two number
ones and and someone right at the that
rb1 rb2 tier then you're ahead of the
game you're feeling great about your
running backs but when we talk about
these wide receivers here's where i have
them right now deontay johnson wide
receiver 23 to me you see his adp 61.3
chase claypool also in my top 30 and
juju smith schuster at wide receiver 36.
that's three steelers in my top 36 at
wide receiver uh i think deontay johnson
to find wide receiver too but with the
others it's gonna be tough for him to
hit his ceiling often so he's a wide
receiver too i would say the same about
dj moore wide receiver 16 for me by the
way robbie anderson a teammate of more
wide receiver 30 his adp a couple spots
higher i think he's a fine wide receiver
too uh i can't get super excited about
sam darnold who would ask a jets fan but
dj moore i think is the clear guy for
the carolina panthers where's deontay
johnson on a better team
has more competition for target so i
think you have a couple of wide receiver
twos here i don't think they have super
upside because of what's going on around
them but at the same token you have
three of my top 13 running backs so i
think it works out okay rashad i think
you did a good job it doesn't matter
where the points come from sometimes
you're just stacked more at one position
than another let's move on to the next
one here and this comes from douglas i
need to keep two standard scoring
dobbins in the fourth round waller in
the sixth round swift in the seventh
justin jefferson in the 13th metcalf in
the 15th people last year good job is it
crazy to keep two wide receivers it is
not
crazy at all and you should keep justin
jefferson at metcalf
unbelievable values here we're talking
about two players that will be gone
inside the top 20 and probably inside
the top 15 picks and you're keeping them
in throwaway rounds in lottery ticket
rounds yes you're starting with two wide
receivers that's fine but you're getting
two bonafide wide receiver ones and i
look at those adps by the way metcalf's
probably safe jefferson i think is
actually a value at 24 right now for the
minnesota vikings uh i love this and by
the way keeping two guys like this means
now you can focus on the running back
position you know if it is best player
available and you still see a wide
receiver you like that's fine but you
are absolutely set you're gonna have a
big advantage with these two guys at the
top of your personal depth chart let's
move on here uh let's see chats uh chat
says if i take uh derek henry at three
and second round aj brown is there do i
take him
for justin jefferson here's what i'll
tell you i have justin jefferson one
spot higher than aj brown so right there
alone i'm going to tell you to take
justin jefferson it's one spot it's not
that big of a deal however
and the numbers are obviously great for
jefferson last year and that should
continue it's good to have some variants
if you can this is a tiebreaker
situation right jefferson brown back to
back for me maybe yourself in rankings
but if you already have derek henry get
a little variance there you get justin
jefferson instead of stacking up the
tennessee titans and don't forget with
aj brown great amazing talented player
but they did add julio jones it's gonna
take some volume away from him and derek
henry is a running machine they're still
gonna rely on him i go justin jefferson
basically just to get some variance get
you away from being too tennessee titan
heavy uh pby amman ross saint brown or
james white and ppr thin at running back
and deep at wide receiver uh i have
james white significantly higher not
exactly an established group of
receivers or really anybody there genre
smith hunter henry banged up james
white's kind of boring right the adp is
exactly where it should be he's going to
catch passes there you got new faces i
mentioned the tight end it's not a great
team you know who knows he's going to be
playing quarterback by that for that
team by the end of the season i would
think it'll be cam show for at least a
little while but james white's kind of
safe he's the stash guy and either one
of these players if you get a couple of
weeks in the season and say i got
injuries i i got to upgrade another
position you're going to cut these kind
of guys loose and you're not going to
miss them james white's going to be the
kind of player that ends up on like
eight of the 12 teams in your league
this year because he'll catch six passes
in the game he'll pick him up then he'll
catch two neither guy gets me really
excited i would stash away him because
when in doubt the patriots will indeed
uh dump it off to him now let's talk
about my
top wide receivers for the season i did
bring up a name that's going to appear
in this list i'm going to start with
devonte adams it certainly helped
that aaron rodgers came back i don't
know if devonte would have been in this
list but it's davonte adams stefan diggs
you talked about the knee earlier if
you're drafting this weekend you might
say you know what i don't want to do
this i'm going to take davonte adams i'm
gonna take tyree kill i'm gonna take
deandre hopkins in arizona and headache
into his second season there calvin
ridley rounds out my top five these are
my top five wide receivers but you saw
names earlier like dk metcalf like
justin jefferson who i think will be
wide receiver ones that you get a little
bit later on how about an allen robinson
in chicago let's hope that quarterback
situation is better this is my top five
group like i said with diggs he's the
only one that has a bit of a question
mark right now because this knee issue
seems to be lingering a little bit
longer to feel that then you'd want to
feel comfortable with so
let's just keep an eye on that situation
if you're drafting at the end of the
month you could be fine by then you're
good to go these are my top five guys
but there is certainly as you take a
look at my rankings uh a lot more depth
high-end depth at the wide receiver
position this season all right as we
begin to wrap things up here it's time
for your burning questions whether
you're watching games this preseason
already uh whether you're kind of
putting things together catching back up
let's help you out chick-fil-a the goat
just had some for lunch uh is this the
year mixing finally goes off or is his
offense and o-line too limiting i mean i
think it's wrong to say he hasn't gone
off yet two years ago the bengals were
awful and joe mixon was great now last
year had the injury as we know uh last
year was a letdown coming off with two
years ago when he was still good and
they looked better
a low end rv one for me the o-line
concerns are fair
uh i think he'll find a bigger role in
the passing game remember no giovanni
bernard there it's a young
talented wide receiver group but joe
mixon is the most established player
there joe burrow being back and healthy
would certainly help
go off i don't think he's going to blow
up this season but i think he'll finish
inside the top 12 at the running back
position uh let's see charles silva here
mahomes are allen qb one
i have mahomes one mahomes actually in
fantasy points per game last year
finished slightly higher
than josh allen here's what i'll say
about this you're not going to go wrong
either way look at the numbers they're
absolutely ridiculous um from a value
standpoint there's no way i'm taking any
quarterback that high
whether it be mahomes at 15 or 27 for
josh allen it's not a position i'm gonna
take that high it's just not necessary
you can get a matthew stafford later on
and jalen hurts even later than that you
can stream the position i'd rather use
those early picks elsewhere i will say i
have my homes over allen mostly because
i trust the offense a little bit more
they both have the legs when in doubt
look for legs you're going to get a lot
of fantasy bonus points that way
but i like the weapons a little bit more
higher end weapons for patrick mahomes
versus josh allen but they're one and
they're two for me uh ak-10 to sequon or
to not say quan that is the question but
i haven't gotten it that much because
look
he had a torn acl it happened early in
the season i'm totally fine with it
remember it's nearly a full year we're
gonna come up on week one when he had
that injury
he's still the most important part of
the offense daniel jones is he gonna
make the jump this season that is the
big question for the new york giants we
had kenny goliday to the mix obviously
he's a little bit banged up but take one
barkley's ready to go
and this is not 10-15 years ago when you
needed an extra year to really bounce
all the way back from the corn acl we've
seen plenty of situations where a guy
can do it and perform at a high level so
yes i am in on saquon barkley although
he is just outside of my top five at the
running back position uh jackie here has
a question i'm in three different
leagues and i want jalen hurts and all
of them good idea or bad idea now i just
talked about jalen hurts i like him as a
sleeper quarterback a player who will
run on a team that's not very good but
do i want to go all in on jalen hurts
that answer is going to be no
because
i'll say this i i think there's upside
here i think will be better in fantasy
versus reality but there's still also an
unproven nature here on a young team i
would rather have some variance at my
quarterback position i'm not at the
point where i'm super excited about
jalen hurst's goal all in on him you
know kylo murray when everybody expected
him to make the jump sure i understood
that there and then he did hertz is
still a work in progress which is fine
he should be
but even if you think he's going to be a
solid fantasy quarterback this season
there's enough questions about him that
you wouldn't go all in on someone like
jalen hurt so get him on a team look
elsewhere for a quarterback on the other
ones let's get one more in here from
booger who is the riskiest player within
the top 15 adp and why also is joe mixon
really worth the hype we talked about
mixing already the hype of a low-end rb1
sure the one player who i like is a
talent but a situation scares me is
jonathan taylor of the indianapolis
colts right now i'd like to have a
better feel for the big injuries on his
o-line with carson wentz
i want to have better vibes about the
team as a whole
when in doubt i think you shy away from
bad teams the numbers were good last
year is 80 p of 8.3 it is just a little
bit too high i'll tell you this
jonathan taylor is the only indianapolis
cult in my top 100 overall rankings
that's telling on its own that tells me
that the team is not very exciting or
not very good and i'm not the only one
that has them ranked accordingly this is
a team with a lot of question marks i
know people like mike pittman i get that
as well you would hope that wayne's can
bounce back but he needed a lot of
things to go right and they haven't gone
right yet i like jonathan taylor as a
player i'd like to feel better about
their situation and because i don't that
adp around eight nine right now is just
a bit too strong he'd be the riskiest
player to me inside the top 15. hey
we're going to get to more of your
questions the next two thursdays right
here on your fantasy fire drill fire
them in there as you're watching the
games you think about them put them in
there i'll be answering them get them in
the br app and i'll be back with you
here for the next two thursdays at 1pm
eastern for your fantasy fire drill as
we lead towards the championship in 2021
i'm matt camp thanks for watching
[Applause]
you